Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
and restarting
back from the beginning in the book of
knowledge of
author authored by Noah.
And for those who are sticking with
these, this is not a class. It's not
even a lecture. It's really just a a
brief statement, if you will, a revision
of a narration.
However, the subjects that I choose for
this gathering after ISha and after fud,
they are never subjects or rarely ever
subjects
that are just
extra additional
extracurricular if you will,
not having to do with oblig obligatory
knowledge for every Muslim and Muslim to
have
the knowledge we discuss here
because knowledge is two types. There is
that of it which is obligatory for every
Muslim to have and there is that of it
which is general and a portion of any
Muslim community have to have this
knowledge and if they have it then it
falls off of the rest and remains
preferable for them to learn.
None of the subjects that we talk about
here are just preferable to learn.
The subjects that we discuss here are
dire critical knowledge
for you and I to make it across a on the
day of judgment.
We're learning
how to get across the bridge,
cast over the pits of hell. That's what
we're learning here. It's not just extra
stuff, you know, good to know, fun
facts.
This is what we need in order to be
placed in our graves and not tortured.
what we need in order to leave behind
a moderate legacy of Islam for the next
generation. What we need to know
in order to be resurrected on the day of
judgment and clothed before Allah.
Because on the day of judgment,
who is the first person to be clothed by
Allah?
Ibraimisam.
And why is that?
What are we clothed by in the hereafter?
Huh?
[Arabic recitation]
when we are resurrected and Allah puts
clothing on people, some people will
have clothing of fire.
Some people will have clothing of
paradise.
What is it that determines that
clothing?
What happened when Adam and his wife ate
from the tree?
And so we are clothed on the day of
judgment by what? By our tawa. By our
tawa. This cannot happen without
knowledge. We have said this so many
times and I it warrants repeating and I
must repeat it
every week, every day if I have to for
us to get the message because deep down
in our subconscious I think that we have
a misunderstanding and that is we think
that if we have a good intention
everything else just is okay. that if I
have a if I have a pure heart and a good
intention,
then I can accidentally make my way
through the gates of paradise. It
doesn't work that way. You have to
actively choose to go to paradise. You
have to know its direction and you have
to put one foot in front of the other to
get there. No one accidentally
stumbles into the love of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. That cannot happen.
No matter how good your intention is.
Good intentions have caused people to
worship the sun, the moon, the stars,
rose, Buddha, trees, each other,
themselves, animals, cows, good
intentions. All of these have good
intentions. Every one of them.
Muslim men who innovate, who introduce
ideas into Islam, actions and rituals
into Islam, good intentions.
And we have in America a u a proverb or
an idiom about good intentions. Do you
know it? Did you grow up in America?
The road to hell is
good intentions.
[Arabic recitation]
close.
good intentions. That's a a saying we
have in America. It rings true in
one context and that is good
intentions with no knowledge.
Some of the worst things that have ever
happened in human history were good
intentions, not
fettered, not bridled by knowledge, not
guided by knowledge. Good intentions,
the best intentions, the most intense
intentions, the purest intentions, no
knowledge.
And where do they end up?
That's where they end up. Good
intentions. Every one of them had good
intentions or many of them. And this is
why every salah, every
we have to recite and we have to ask
Allah
17 separate times a day.
Guide us the path of those whom your
grace is upon,
not the path
of those whom have in who have
incurred your anger nor those
misguided.
Notice the wording here. These are three
groups of people with respect to
knowledge and actions. Those whom
Allah's grace is upon,
they are those
who have knowledge and implement that
knowledge. Those are the ones whom
Allah's grace is upon.
The ones who have incurred the anger.
And notice the wording here. He didn't
say
we're speaking to Allah.
you would expect it to be.
That's not what is said. rather ald
meaning in those whom the anger is upon.
Meaning it's as if the entire existence
the hellfire the good the bad the angels
the inanimate objects all of them have
their anger and the arrows of their
anger directed to these people. Who are
these people? Those who have knowledge
but do not implement that knowledge.
Those are
and
they are the ones who have good
intentions and no knowledge.
Their actions are not guided by
knowledge.
Kind of like
if if I were to say, "Come with me. I
would to take you to Phoenix
and I have the ability to take you. I
have the knowledge to get there and I
take you there. This is
rewarding. This is a good deed.
If I were to say, "Come with me. I want
to take you to Phoenix." And then I know
how to get there, but I start stalling
and telling you stories and drive in the
wrong direction purposely and take you
the opposite direction of Phoenix.
This is a person who has knowledge but
does not implement it. That is very
nefarious. Takes a sick person to do
that.
And then we have those who have great
intentions. Hop in. I'll take you there.
I don't know how to get there, but I
have the car and let's go. So, I just
head off into the sunset, right?
You know, I have great intentions, but I
drove you around for 3 days and we never
made it there. But I had really good
intentions. My heart was pure the whole
trip.
This is the dynamic of knowledge and
actions.
Those whom Allah's anger is upon are the
ones who know but do not do.
Those whom are misguided are the ones
who do not know but do a lot and it
equals zero
because it's not good enough to just
have good intentions. As a matter of
fact, it's almost impossible because how
can you have good intentions without
knowledge anyways?
And so when the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam arrived and the message of
Islam reached a person they are one of
two types. Either they are the ones whom
Allah's grace is upon or the one whom
Allah's anger is upon because the the
truth has come. There is no more
misguidance. I don't know the way and I
have no way to reach it or receive it.
Men and women bled for this religion
and we suffer. The greatest suffering we
have
is having to fast in Ramadan. The
greatest suffering we have is we didn't
have any meat with a meal today. Just
one of our three meals. The greatest
suffering we have is we come to the
masid and somebody didn't turn the AC
on. So, it's kind of hot in the masid
and I got to sweat a little bit while
I'm making salah. It was uncomfortable,
but I did it for the sake of Allah.
Right? That's where we are. We have to
change this. We have to change it now.
Today, not tomorrow. One day, you're
going to come in here and it's going to
be the last time you ever come in here.
And one day, you're going to come in
here. It's going to be the last time.
You probably won't know it. 99% chance
you will not know when your last salah
is going to be. One day I'm going to sit
on this chair for the last time and not
know. And I cannot in any way prove that
it will not be today.
I can't prove that.
So this cannot be put off till tomorrow.
It has to change today.
Now. Tonight. Right now.
And we don't suffer from a lack of
knowledge really. We suffer from a lack
of action because we're hesitant. And
hesitancy kills. So we will redo the
book of knowledge inshallah and then
transition from that into the book of
virtues and follow that with the book of
prohibitions. All from
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu
for
[Silence]
being a Muhammad.
What you got?
How you doing?
[Arabic recitation]